[Music]
Airbnb aggression news oh la half a head
one submitted by love from Nick Mach
Nick Mackie I think is that like a Irish
Asian pick Maki
except it's not him it's not him seat
miak oh oh okay
an air baby guest is hospitalized after
a landlord pushes her down the stairs
after failing to check out on time oh
you got to make that money on time honey
next guest mom that's not like a bull
[ __ ] next guess what I've never heard
this story but what if it was a Hilton
or a Marriott game over right but this
is kind of this new Abby and Airbnb yeah
it's cool I don't even know who's right
or wrong so it's okay well let's hear
the story then you might be better I
feel like I've been late a couple of
times but not like no one got mad you
know it's like I just gonna be a little
bit late on it even a half yeah I think
it's different though like a non-joking
now because these people are running a
business and they're not trying to be
customer service right the who's answer
the phone at Hilton that's will have
been trained who's answering the phone
for the taxi driver a lot of people want
good reviews too so the only that's true
they're annoying yeah I turn annoying
but for leave me alone yeah I thought
not yeah don't go out of the way to make
sure everything looks perfect and all
that yeah oh is it a house or is it like
apartment or sometimes you can share oh
yeah like you render than I mean yeah
that could change you're just laying on
the cup that's a little different if
you're just in the room and you're just
laying on the couch you're so let's
check out three hours ago
that's all yeah dude we're like having a
birthday party yeah [ __ ] out so this
takes place and Amsterdam I'm stirred
out of course I thought America I don't
know why it sounds like American
behavior selfish [ __ ] I thought it was
American too the violence is always like
America yeah I don't picture Amsterdam
in Union it did not supposed to be the
best country reliving the world in the
world I don't remember that I've heard
that like nicest and cleanest and is not
over green absolutely not Amsterdam yeah
that whole roll is not green well that's
where you're trying to get [ __ ] good
hi that's not where you're trying to
a little are you talking about the
red-light district yes it's very clean
it's Holland right yep yeah I think
Holland is in general like yep it's
pretty clear I got a bunch of random
facts it apart how can you have such
like beautiful architecture and like a
normal suburb area and then Las Vegas
right across the street it feels more
normal than Vegas right way more normal
yeah like Vegas like it's in your face I
know it works
oh and Hollander Webber and Cherie Jaffe
yeah yeah you I feel normally so there's
no public drunks there is yeah but
they're not being rowdy the are don't
ask American you don't know yeah what's
the difference now would you be happy
they're just like yeah yeah yeah let's
go let go let go don't you feel like
that too much yeah like that it's just
happy people rather than people are
driving by in a car and then like
sticking the rooted people very
belligerent behavior we don't you don't
really see that it's just like so
they're not douchebags
no like 10 people I just finished
watching a soccer game yes very happy
and they're just like kata Leninism run
around
well this landlord must've been an
American yeah anything violent it's like
our fault so this one her name is sue
Bali she's a South African filmmaker who
is currently studying in Switzerland but
was in Amsterdam for an exhibition what
is she doing like play with her [ __ ]
lips mm-hmm uh-huh
I think I'm just an artist then they you
say director she's a filmmaker yeah oh
man but not the actress yeah maybe she
films other girls playing with a [ __ ]
look what I think after then I think was
section [ __ ] way well maybe
they have more than that you gosh it was
like wiping the lens it's really
accurate sex weed and wooden clogs I
didn't see any wooden clogs let your I
think wooden clogs I know uh windmill is
now huh oh yeah windmills and good
kickboxing women on a windmill coconut
joint I need to go there before so bad
right now
Jorgen is not right
what did you do that that's what they
sound like I'm so raises right now
finish it off with a ching chong ching
chong in your head kang dong yeah yeah
yeah yeah my people say that yes any gap
ching chong Ling long Cheng Han ding
dong yes yeah so I'm going to show you
guys the clip and right here you're
going to see her arguing with the
landlord so what they're saying is
before this recording that the wife of
the landlord came came to them and said
okay you know you guys are saying
overtime and you guys got leap and then
that's when she was just saying like
we're so sorry we're leaving right now
we're just packing up we just woke up
later for whatever reason so her and her
three friends they just continued to
pack up and a couple minutes later
that's when the husband shows up and
then he starts being super angry and she
asked him like why are you being
emotional like relieving calm down me
just like else out and then you'll see
the rest it's on video like life someone
without a cell or something yeah because
he started getting yeah really emotional
technologies don't come agrandi got
video so here we go and by the way huge
spacing um census murder
oh no attempt attempt yeah he tried to
pale man you don't know like laws in
other countries you know like attempted
murder here
like this could be attempted murder in
Holland for always chewing gum and
spitting it out could be attempted
[ __ ] world disasters single water
yeah biological [ __ ] terrorism oh he
was not what are you thinking right now
why are you talking oh oh oh oh
[Music]
Oh Paul would she break her neck oh no
so luckily she danced with fanny serious
injuries she [ __ ] flew out like that
stairs were frictionless she went down
like it was a slip and slide [ __ ] up
cheers what goes you laughing that [ __ ]
look like she was done a slide headfirst
like it's like a three-year-old kid at
the park it's like in Raging Waters it
did look like an insane we're not a [ __ ]
like it was an air hockey table
live it up mom hormones you evil G Oh
[Laughter]
laughing at our misery right now
a melon broke her neck I didn't say
anything why are you laughing oh so
funny saying oh excuse me
Yeah right you're laughing at her
that's blows out yes this is her H oh ah
that's after that was really good all
good look I'll get you Tom looks like a
photo so she gay to wave around a little
mention her sexuality I connect the
[ __ ] God okay maybe it was this
chick she was doing mm all right
whatever
to get into the cables boys the
photographer is in South Africa thank
you okay she films what she films but
that's what oh that's really bad
thousand I thought good Oh her friend
was very sad like someone sat down but I
wouldn't even stop was the bone sticking
or something was your friend stone so
crazy like it is a crazy in its
intensity movie about moving yeah fell
down like she flew down though no
healthy sister did she have something
anyway he actually pushed her down the
stairs and keep in mind European stairs
are hella steep a little way you don't
have to pay so it's so American stairs
it's like this European stairs are like
this it's like a ladder that's why we're
more fit and you can also fit your whole
flip on a step here - yeah there's like
a hapis yeah
you might be off it what do they do
[ __ ] give you a spare from toontown
and [ __ ] there's a mechanism so when
people were smaller like three feet tall
ten more stairs of 2000 we the judge are
big when she fell he was the one yelling
I call ambulance or something like that
or yeah Cordy umbrellas what a [ __ ]
dude he is a [ __ ] you know what I
don't understand though it seemed like
there were like three friends right
there was one lady like moving the bags
out he kind of centered it on one the
other one was recording the hold and one
was downstairs kind of right there by
the door I saw what the roller bag yeah
so like if there's three people that
he's trying to kick out why are you
pushing one there's still two inside the
house I'm sure I mean I've never hosted
on everybody but I'm sure he just
charged him for another day yeah
and that's the end of that right hey you
went over sorry you're going to be
charged for tomorrow unless another
guest is coming in but even worse case
right then you get double your money did
they have a fight or something that you
like something happened I don't know I
think we're thinking too logical don't
like at that point you're not even
thinking you're apologizing is very
maybe they clogged the toilet and wrote
this mom this is the Dookie oh I know
what happened it has nothing to do with
the people his wife got mad they got to
a bucket argument right before he got to
the house so he's taking out his rage
toward his wife with the ladies poor
lady man oh yeah she got a concussion
over there so she passed out who's the
wife not she didn't know hey also pretty
much she did have like internal injuries
and bruises but they don't going to
details as to whether that's bad dude
but she was just saying that once she
fell down the stairs should pass - she
woke up in hospital oh that's a bad she
need to make a film about this [ __ ]
use her talent for good and that boy
needs to go to jail for a long time
customer can't be a joke if is even if
they were being rowdy and [ __ ]
[ __ ] like yeah I think the civil way
is just alright then just leave when you
can I have to charge you another day I
just can't picture throwing women down
the [ __ ] stairs for any reason maybe
he wasn't trying to maybe was just
trying to like not turn okay
are you a nice girl yeah yeah keep
[ __ ] through her I'll replay all
right yeah
he's [ __ ] manhandled her like she's a
damn rag doll I'll be must not be oh boy
why why are you talking I think anyone
is all ganged up oh no oh wow you've
gotta get a really bad review I can see
it coming yeah it must be bad what's
Airbnb sly Billy I don't know I don't
think that's a big issue Restylane
that's on him that's not nothing there
baby I hope so and everything beautiful
did have a small statement they said
quote appalling and unconscionable
behavior against members of our
community runs counter to everything or
being V stand for it we will take the
strongest actions we can against such
apparent conduct including banning
people for life from our platform and
assisting law enforcement with their
investigation and potential prosecution
no one's ever be treated like this and
will not be tolerated go adventure he
beat his wife probably you know why
because I can't imagine myself grabbing
a woman that way and throwing her I
can't even do that that's true no matter
how yeah even a guy though like come on
well it's just like I just try to reason
like obviously there's some kind of
language barrier right because he's just
not for guys who gave me excuse to beat
this guy that there's no yeah about
white bean assassin to push him down I
would just say like a bro like you get
out on you it's weird man being able to
pay attention and movement though when
he's moving her he's still holding on to
her there wasn't a hard push as well T
after she was falling yeah she reached
over to so I don't think he actually
meant to throw her but he's probably
seeing red he's still mad that doesn't
TIG rough day I've actually done
something close to now not push somebody
down the stairs push some on downstairs
haha I've broken my mom's nose on
accident
hahaha what did you [ __ ] do bro laughs
oh wow she came behind me and scared me
and my leg came up and I kicked in some
baby boy I was like why mom did a fish
she was like crying and [ __ ] I was like
oh my god I'm so sorry
yeah like I didn't I I went through that
phase where I didn't know my own control
yeah I know and like never do like yeah
and like I had a really bad temper
problem too so like I can kind of
understand his situation a little bit
seeing red and not being able to control
but you're a grown-ass man you can't do
that kind of she looked like he was in
his mid to late forties nothing yeah I
look like a 14 you're having then what's
up guys thanks for watching we are going
to regularly start posting content on
the JK films Instagram so make sure you
follow us there a lot videos click over
here
[Music]
you